Tôi yêu đàn đáng, đây là lần thứ hài tôi đến đây
và thực sự là tôi rất yêu thình của này
Chức đây tôi từng sống một thời gian ở mayamij
người ta vẫn hay nói đưa ra rằng
đàn đáng là mayamij của Việt Nam
mà phải nói điều đó hoàn con chuyện xác
có rất yêu thử tự tịch vời
giữ luật về tôi
có lẽ điều tựa quên nhất là bại biển
bại liền tựa đẹp và sập khoảng
là sân khấu tựa quên, chân những mang biểu gì
tôi đã nói được sống đặc đi vỷ đi
em, mình sẽ không có thể thích sự hồng phúc khi được giữ mi
nhưng khi mà, tôi đã thích sống ở nạn và người ta như thật
người đầy đầy, người ta có tốt đầy
thì vầy việc quay trường hảo và điều chuyện
cho phúc tạm người chúng quay
và kết thánh giả lạ đưa vui
tự vời vô quên ý nghĩa
có lẽ thì hảm ơn, tự vời, đầy khi mọi người
đã thích phy nhớ cũng vực
mình để giữ tuổi từ ngoài nữa
thì tầy bị rộng đầy
giữ